well here's one thing that we know
Donald Trump cannot hide any longer the
payment to stormy Daniels Stephanie
Clifford the adult film star actress who
Trump's lawyer last week came out and
said you know what I made the hundred
and thirty thousand dollar payment to
miss Clifford that was me it wasn't
illegal so let's all move on Trump had
nothing to do with this well as it turns
out MSNBC legal analyst believes that
this payment to miss Clifford stormy
Daniels could actually now be
investigated by robert muller and the
special prosecutor's office why because
it is essentially an in-kind
contribution to the donald trump
campaign and therefore would violate the
limits on what an individual is allowed
to donate to a presidential campaign
here's what they're saying right now if
this payment was made to Stephanie
Clifford stormy Daniels in an attempt to
aid the donald trump campaign then yes
100% it is an in-kind contribution to
the Trump campaign was not disclosed
exceeded the limits on acceptable
campaign donations and therefore would
be illegal finding a mr. Cohen Donald
Trump's lawyer who says he made the
payment out of his own pocket
this guy's gonna find himself in very
unpleasant legal hot water at this point
so if Muller is now looking into that
payment we have yet another branch added
to this special prosecution tree because
this goes beyond any of the things we've
already seen it has nothing to do with
the kushner financials has nothing to do
with the Russian interference or the
Russian collusion part of the
investigation no this is now a whole
other branch of the tree that has
sprouted in the last few weeks only to
be made worse by Trump's lawyer himself
by saying yes I made the payment
and here's the thing you cannot expect
that this guy made this payment by
himself without the knowledge of anyone
else he set up an LLC in a different
state put the money into there had that
little corporation that he created write
the check to stormy Daniels lawyer no
know nothing about that story makes
sense nothing about it is plausible
there had to have been other human
beings involved and that is hopefully
what Robert Muller and his team are also
looking at right now and they've got a
lot on their plate I ain't good grief at
this point it seems like every week or
two we're finding a new a new thread to
follow and this stormy Daniels one is a
story that obviously the Trump
administration has been fairly mum about
they haven't said too much about it but
we do know that since the story broke
things had been a little iffy I guess
you'd say between Melania and Donald
himself but there's something to this
this is more than just a Trump had an
affair with an adult film star that's
secondary you know that's a personal
issue that's not even an impeachable
offense by any stretch of the
imagination but this payment this hush
money that was paid to her that's the
story and I think that's the main reason
that the Trump administration is staying
oddly silent about the story because
they understand that this one has real
ramifications for them they can't lie
their way out of this the lawyer already
admitted to doing it you know the the
story from from years ago has already
been told it happened the payment
happened and last week miss Daniels miss
Clifford scuse me said that yes she's
gonna tell her story now at least her
lawyer said she was and hopefully the
first person to hear that story about
the payment and about everything that
took place to keep her quiet the first
person to hear about that should be
Robert Muller and then immediately after
talking to her he needs to pull in Coen
Donald Trump's lawyer and say okay
you tell me what happened and I'm gonna
see how that measures up to what miss
Clifford just told me I'm fairing
cousins in for David Pakman we got to
take a quick break but we'll be right
back with more of the David Pakman show